adele is a gift that keeps on giving
even on her birthday
the singer is celebrating her 33rd trip
around the sun
by blessing us with never-before-seen
photos of herself
she's been mia on the gram since january
but
clearly she's been living her best life
in the first photo adele is makeup free
showing off her long blonde locks in a
tattoo
on her forearm in the second shot the 33
year old appears to be
out of office and carefree in the ocean
and in the last image the birthday girl
is twirling all her troubles away in a
tie-dye dress
adele captioned the stunning series 30
free
you set me free
friends took to social to honor the
singer like laura dockrill who posted
this throwback pic yeah adele is totally
unrecognizable
as she's embodying the late george
michael laura captioned it
make sure you're bff with someone that
also goes to fancy dress parties
not dressed as a sexy cat i love you so
much adele happy birthday
it's been a complete whirlwind while the
singer is feeling free on her special
day
a bunch of fans in the comments had one
major question on their mind
where's the dm album i know there's been
a lot of chatter about me just being the
host
i've seen all of it like why isn't she
the musical guest and stuff like that
and there's a couple of reasons
well adele addressed the new album when
she hosted saturday night live
last fall my album's not finished and
i'm also too scared to do both
adele first teased new music in 2019 and
rumor has it the album is coming later
this year
but get this close friend and british
comedian
alan carr revealed to grazia uk he's
actually heard some tracks from the new
album calling the songs he listened to
so amazing
and even though the grammy winner has
been staying low-key
adele was recently spotted at this
oscar's after party
in one video adele is seen dancing to a
jennifer
lopez and jaw world throwback hit i'm
real
the night out comes soon after her
divorce was finalized from
ex simon konecki in march the couple
agreed to share
joint custody of eight-year-old son
angelo how's it being a new mom
very tiring wonderful but tiring
safe to say adele is entering a new
phase in her life
[Music]